the owner second is the second after you
make a terrible mistake the second one
you realize what you just did and
there's nothing you can do about it the
second when all the now inevitable
consequences flashed through your mind
it is the second after you send a text
message to the wrong person after you
delete the wrong file after you spill
the secret that you thought they already
knew the owner second is that stomach
dropping the red stopping moment when
all you can do is say oh no this is the
story of the worst typo I ever made I
[Music]
was maybe 18 or 19 in charge of
converting an old website to a new and
faster platform a half dozen volunteers
had spent days transferring all the
articles over copying them from the old
site updating them and then saving them
in their new place it had been a lot of
effort but everything was pretty much
sorted now there's just one thing I need
to do searching the place across all
those pages of content and I was wise to
the mistake that people usually make
there it's called the robotic mistake
where someone wants to censor the word
ass and the search for place gets a
little bit more enthusiastic than they
thought it would this problem much
simple the volunteers have just written
the articles in plain text I needed to
add some simple formatting anywhere that
there were three dashes I just needed to
replace that with a tank for a
horizontal line and there's no way that
that search of a place can go wrong
right this was the mid 2000s so the site
wasn't anything fancy was a standard
sequel database sequel SQL is structured
query language it's an international
standard for sending commands to basic
databases and it's still used today I
haven't bothered to set up any tools to
help me along with it I was the only one
working on the site so I was just using
the command line which and that with a
single instruction I could change every
record in the live database every single
page at once and working on the live
databases are a little bit like working
with a live mains electricity cable sure
it's physically possible it'd make
things quicker and there are very very
rare occasions where it might actually
be the only option but in general if you
are working on mains electricity you
turn the power off first and if you are
working on a database you don't work on
the line
version that was working on the light
bush because I was young and I was
careless and besides that the difficult
part was over right after all that
conversion work and it was a lot of work
I just had to assure a few final
commands update the list of articles and
set the content field to itself
just with the dashes replaced with a tag
so I typed in the command hit enter and
oh no reading 5,000 pages to research
from the place cost all that text I'm
putting it back into the database should
have taken a bit more than one
hundredths of a second I didn't know
what had happened yet but I knew
something had gone wrong
hold that thought in the history of
computer science the undo command was
invented independently several times in
the 1970s problems are the Xerox PARC
Research Center for the first to assign
it to that easy to reach keyboard
shortcut of ctrl Z or said their work
there later on inspired many features
that ended up an act of computers and
most of the time undo is linear there is
an ordered list of commands that we've
issued and we can undo or redo our way
back and forth through that list the
most basic way to implement that is to
store the exact state of the document
after every single command or even after
each keystroke and then just roll back
to that it's memory intensive and there
are a lot of ways to optimize it but
that'll work it's also an easy mental
model for users to deal whether you just
step back and forth in time but if you
go back in time and then make a small
change you won't be able to redo your
way back for words like a time traveller
in science fiction you have broken the
future so if you do want to recover
something you delete it and bring it
forward in time with you you're gonna
have to be really careful not to
accidentally hit the wrong key while
you're back there now plenty of folks
have tried to create undo trees so if
you do go back and change history just
create a new timeline and you can move
around the timelines however you want
there are some text editors which will
do that for you and even visualize all
the branches but it's a complicated
thing to keep in your head and it's
never found mainstream appeal there are
source control systems that work the
same way like get every time you save
your file and commit
it that copy is available forever
multiple people can work on files at the
same time make changes in different
branches and everything just gets merged
back together afterwards it is
incredibly useful for any software
development project but trying to do
that for every keystroke rather than
every saved version of a file is a bit
much saving keystrokes works in memory
which is fast saving files works on disk
which is comparatively slow Microsoft
Word used to have a fast save feature
wherever you'd updated oh just a few
things in the document it didn't
actually save the whole thing all over
again it just appended those changes on
the end so you didn't have to wait five
or ten seconds every time you hit ctrl s
to save on all 90s computer yeah it
turned out that saving stuff in files
that users thought they deleted was a
massive premise in security risk than
that cut turned off in 2003 that model
quick undo for live working memory and a
slower save to disk when you're done
with a task is still used in a lot of
places although it is slowly changing if
you write text in Google Docs or other
cloud-based platforms then your
keystrokes are constantly saved and
synchronized you never actually have to
hit save which means that depending on
which app you're working in you have to
change your mental model of how your
work is saved and sometimes you don't
want to save every single keystroke in
command if you've got frustrated if your
boss typed some colorful comments into
your code and then deleted them they
probably shouldn't be stored forever or
maybe you accidentally pasted a password
or a security key or credit card number
into the wrong file and you definitely
don't want directly in turn to have
access to that forevermore anyway the
point is there are all sorts of systems
big and small designed to allow you to
undo and redo in my sequel the language
I was using for that database they had
transactions and you could type the
command to start transaction and any
edits you made would be accepted but
they wouldn't actually properly
definitely irrevocably saved until the
type commits if you screwed up you type
rollback other than the database just
forgot those commands and ever been sent
in which is great right because everyone
makes typos
can you spot it because it's really
subtle the database have gone to the
articles table and for every single
article it had change the content field
those words articles and content they're
surrounded by back ticks that odd
carriage to the left the one on most
keyboards backticks mean this is the
name of a table or field I'm referring
to something in a database and that's
all fine and I look to the replace
command and I told it that for each
article it should pull the content and
replace the dashes with the tag
everything's in the right order there I
remember checking that going all the
right way round except that's where I
messed up those right there they're not
backticks they're apostrophes and
apostrophes mean this is a literal
string of text not a name so as I had
ordered the database promptly took the
literal word content cont ent look fruit
for Dash is found on replace nothing and
then put that word into the content
field for five thousand articles and I
looked at the website all the volunteers
hard work five thousand pages every
single page just replaced with the word
content genuinely are my pulse rate is
rising a little as I think about that I
was I was nearly physically sick because
I knew what was going to happen next
because that typo is an entirely
reasonable mistake to make this there's
nothing wrong with screwing up like that
everyone makes errors like that all the
time and we hit ctrl Z or we click the
undo button in Gmail we hit undo send at
least for the 30 seconds before it
actually does send the message and if
you happen to be enough of a prat to be
working on a live sequel database you
type in rollback
I haven't told it to start a transaction
and there are all sorts of words that I
can use to describe the idea of working
on a live database without even a
transaction as a safety net ridiculous
asinine and thinking but the one I think
is most accurate is negligent the only
reason that typo was the worst I've ever
made was because of all the poor
decisions that led up to it working on a
live database thinking that I couldn't
screw up one simple command not having
any sort of backup
days of work by volunteers and at no
point during that I thought you know
what maybe maybe we should get a copy of
that somewhere else just just in case
like that should have been backed up
daily or hourly the root cause of all
that of all the days afterwards where I
had to apologize to so many people the
root cause wasn't one typo it was the
overconfidence and negligence that meant
I didn't have any way to undo my
mistakes the sort of lesson you only
learn once programmers and anyone who
works with software we have this magical
ability to undo no professional that
works with physical real-world things
has that option so if you don't have a
backup of your code or your thesis or
the photos on your phone all your
database get a backup don't put it off
for the future and if you do have one
ready check it works because you don't
want to have the same feeling of oh no
if you're techie enough to make it to
the end of this video then you should
definitely be using a password manager
every so often you'll see a big news
article about how companies had a
security breach and yeah sometimes
that's what's happened but other times
it's just that someone has found or
bought a list of usernames and passwords
from another security breach at a
different company and is just trying all
of them to see if there are any matches
reusing the same password or variations
on it is a bad idea
so I recommend dashlane as a password
manager partly because they're
sponsoring this video but also because
I've read the security white paper and
solve a lot of other people who know
more about cryptography than me being
able to easily use long complicated
symbol filled passwords that are
different for every website and app
automatically synchronized across iOS
Android Windows Mac and Linux is
incredibly useful plus they will
autofill credit card info and personal
details if you want and if you're
working from home right now for some big
company then sure your company's IT
might be working great but maybe you're
in the position where you've got ten
people who all need to share an account
on some other company's service and the
one person who knows the password can't
just walk over to your desk and log you
in anymore so instead of sending that
password over email or slack or calling
someone up and them write it down - Lane
for business lets teams of people share
passwords securely go to - Lang comm
slash Tom Scott to try - Lang for free
and you can use my code Tom Scott for
10% off - flame premium and to support
this channel
you